في هذه الساعه نبدا من تطورات حرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا حيث اعلنت السلطات المواليه
لروسيا في دونيت تقدم القوات الروسيه شمال
مطار المدينه وقرب مدينه غورلوفكا في محور
مايوركا
لمتابعه تطورات الوضع على الارض معنا من
اكرامتوس مراسله الجزيره عامر لافي ومن
دونيسك مراسل الجزيره امين درغامي وبما ان
القوات الروسيه
والموالون لها يتحدثون عن تقدم ماذا
تقول هذه القوات تحديدا في هذا المحور
ماسكك امين
حسن التاكيد كان على لسان رئيس جمهوريه
دنيا
فرقه او كتيبه الصومال التي تقاتل الى
جانب القوات المواليه لروسيا هنا في دنيا
والمتواصله منذ يوم امس الى غايه اليوم
على بلده برغو ماي سكوير بلده تقع شمال
البلده التي كانت القوات الروسيه قد سيطرت
عليها قبل نحو شهرين ايضا
اكد على ان هناك تقدم للقوات الروسيه في
بلده مايوركا وهي احدى بلدات الطوق
المعروفه هنا في دونباس وتقع الى الشمال
الغربي من مدينه جورلافكار احدى المدن هنا
يبدو ان تركيز على هذا المحور له همم يعني
هدفين اساسيين الاول يتمثل في منع وقوع
هجمات على مدينه غورلف كالتي تقع على خط
التماسي الفاصل بين الجانبين ومن جهه اخرى
فتح الطريق الجنوبي امام القوات الروسيه
من اجل الالتحاق
باقوات فاجنر وبالتالي تشكيل طوق حول
مدينه ضخموت التي مازالت المعارك تدور على
اطرافها همم طبعا في محاوله لاقتحام هذه
المدينه ايضا جبهه اخرى لا تقل احده فيها
المعارك وهي جبهه اوبلدار التي تحدثت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اليوم على انها كبدت
الجيش الاوكرانيه خسائر كبيره كما قال
المتحدث باسم الوزاره وفعليا تلك المنطقه
ما زال تشهد قرا وفرا بين الجانبين وخاصه
في بلده القريبه من اوبريدار هنا في
المحور الجنوبي من مدينه دنياك ايضا في
خرسون هناك تطورات مهمه قبل قليل فقط
السلطات المواليه لروسيا هناك اعلنت عن
سقوط مروحين اطلقهما الجيش الاوكرانيين في
محيطه محطه القطارات في مدينه خيسون وقالت
بان الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه استطاعت ان
تتصدى الى صاروخين من طراز هايمارس
امريكيه الصنع ولم تعلن حتى الان عن اي
حصيله في الضحايا جرار هذا القصف الذي
يتزمن ايضا مع تواصل عمليات الاجلاء همم
اجلاء طبعا المدنيين من الضفه اليمنى
للنهار النيترو وخاصه من كخوفك والموفقك
خوفك وبعض الاجزاء ايضا المحيطه بمدينه
خرسون وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اليوم وفي
بيانها قالت ان القوات الروسيه صدت هجمات
عديده للجيش الاوكراني هنا في اقليم جمباز
وايضا في مقاطعه خارقين وتحدثت عن تكبير
القوات الاوكرانيه خسائر كبيره فنسمع الى
ما قالت الوزاره
على محاور القتال في مختلف الجبهات الحلقه
القوات الروسيه خسائر بصفوف وحدات القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه وتمكنت قواتنا في
مناطق بجمهوريه دونيسك الشعبيه من قتل
اكثر من 120 جنديا ودمرنا ناقلتي جند
ومدرعتين وشاحنه دفن رباعي وعربيتين وفي
محوريمان في جمهوريه تم القضاء على اكثر
من 60 عسكريه وتدمير عدد من المعدات
العسكريه اما في محور كوبيانس قتلنا اكثر
من 140 جنديا اوكرانيا وفي مقاطعه خرسا
على محور
اكثر من 80 جنديا وتدمير ثلاث مركبات
قتاليه
على نفس المحور
ابقى معنا امين درغامي عامر لا في
منكرامتورز ماذا تقول القوات الاوكرانيه
اذا اما تعلن روسيا والمولون لها عن هذا
التقدم في اكثر من محور في دنيتك
قبل قليل تحدث حاكم دونيسك عن الوضع
الانساني
كما هو الحال منذ فتره على طول الخطوط
المواجهه في مقاطعه الدونيس قال اا حاكم
هذه المقاطعه بان القوات الروسيه وهنا
اتهمها بانها تستهدف وتتعمد استهداف
المدنيين في هذه المدينه اليوم يقول قتل
اثنين من سكان هذه المدينه واصيب ثمانيه
بالامس على سبيل المثال خمسه من سكان هذه
المدينه قتلوا اصيب عدد كبير ايضا من
سكانها وفقا لما قاله حاكم هذه المدينه
قال ايضا بان السلطات الاوكرانيه تسعى
جاهده لاخلاء هذه المدينه من السكان هي
مدينه كبيره بالمناسبه يعني حسن وبالتالي
يقومون يوميا كما يقول حاكم دونيكس باخلاء
تقريبا خمسمائه شخص يوميا من سكان هذه
المدينه الى مناطق اكثر امنا بالحديث طبعا
على الجبهه ذكرنا هي الاعنف وهي الاقوى
محور باخمود سوليدار لكن الله القوات
الاوكرانيه ومصادر هناك تحدثت لنا عن انها
تمكنت اليوم من صد هجمات عديده للقوات
الروسيه وبالفعل تمكنت من ارجاع هذه
القوات الى خطوط خلفيه وبالتالي هي حصلت
وقوت من خطوط دفاعاتها على هذه المدينه
لكن طبعا يعترفون بان الوضع صعب هناك
القوات الروسيه التي تقود المعارك هناك
همم بمصاحبه مقاتلي شركه فاجنر هم همم حسن
همم لا يبعدون عن المدينه سوى تقريبا خمسه
كيلو مترات وبالتالي الوضع هناك ما زال
صعبا ايضا هناك من محاولات التقدم التي
سالت عنها في المنطقه الجنوبيه من مقاطع
ليس هناك اي تصريح اوكراني يتحدث عن هذا
الموضوع توصلنا مع مصادر عسكريه في
المنطقه الجنوبيه قالوا لنا بان قواتنا
الاوكرانيه كما قالوا ما زالت في اماكنها
لا يوجد تغيير في شكل التحرك في تلك
المنطقه بل يتحدث عن صبهم لهجوم عنيف كما
وصفوه لي قوات الروسيه في المحور الجنوبي
وتحديدا في اوغلدار وقالوا بانهم كبدوا
القوات الروسيه المتقدمه هناك خسائر كبيره
والحقوا بها الكثير من الخسائر سواء في
الجنود وفي الاليه
في في هذه النقطه بدات بالجانب الانساني
عامر لا في تلك المناطق التي يشتد فيها
القتال الان ولا تتغير كما تقول الخارطه
العسكريه وفقا لما تعلنه القوات
الاوكرانيه كيف يبدو همم وضع المدنيين
هناك في حين اننا مثلا في خير همم لاحظنا
محاولات روسيه لاخلاء المدنيين ماذا عن
المناطق همم الاخرى من الجانب الاوكراني
في الدنيا
نعم حسن يعني الحرب لم تبدا حديثا يعني
اكثر من ثمانيه اشهر وعمليه الاخلاء
ومطالبه السكان بالاخلاء هي مستمره منذ
بدايه الحرب دي عالم نحن مغطينا في مناطق
عده وتحديدا هنا في المنطقه الشرقيه هذا
هذه مناشده يوميا وعمليه الاخلاء هي عمليه
شبه يوميه لكن هناك كثير من سكان هذه
المناطق الحسن يرفضون الاخلاق والرغم من
حيث السلطات الاوكرانيه لهم لترك هذه
المناطق مدينه مكروس هي المدينه التي
تعتبر مركز لعمليه الاخلاق واذكر هنا
بانها استهدفت اليوم وامس هذه المدينه
التي كان ينظر لها على انها مدينه امنه
همم حركه القطارات لم تتوقف فيها على
الرغم منذ بدء الحرب حتى الان لذلك كان
يتم نقل هؤلاء المدنيين الذين يتم اخلاهم
من المدن الاوكرانيه سواء في دونيسك او في
لوغانس عندما كانت تسيطر القوات
الاوكرانيه على العديد من المدن المذكر
طبعا بالاستشانسيفردوس التي تم اخلاء معظم
سكانها وكلي هؤلاء السكان معظمهم عن طريق
هذه المدينه التي قصفت بالامس وقصفت اليوم
ايضا وبالتالي عمليه الاخلاء مستمره الامر
الاخر السلطات الوكرانيه تتعامل مع الذين
يرفضونه الاخلاء بالسعي لدعمهم على سبيل
المثال نحن بدانا موسم الشتاء هناك ازمه
في الغاز لذلك بدات السلطات هنا بتوزيع
الاخشاب لاستخدامها في عمليات التدفئه بدل
الغاز الذي هو مقطوع في كثير من الاماكن
نعم حسن شكرا جزيلا لك عامر في منكراموس
وشكرا لامين ضرغامي من دنياز